a rare sight on the French German border
German police Manning checkpoints from
now on cross-border traffic will be at a
near standstill the borders to Denmark
Switzerland Austria and Luxembourg will
also be almost completely shut Rison the
only drifting guys account people
without significant reason to travel
will not be allowed to cross the border
in either direction and citizens to
cancel all non-essential travel across
the border bidding Tolleson commuters
will not be affected by the shutdown and
goods will still be able to cross the
border unhindered anyone displaying
symptoms of coronavirus infection will
be handed over to the health authorities
there's no set timeframe for these
travel restrictions and the government
says it might extend them to borders
with other neighboring countries it's
tough and I see new beasts viele it's
important that as few people as possible
are infected so we have to try to slow
the rate of infection there are really
problematic areas in France which is why
we took this decision in order to slow
the spread of the virus along some for
now the restrictions only apply on the
ground air travel is not affected German
Chancellor Angela Merkel is missing with
her cabinet later to decide if the skies
are to remain open staying on the ground
and for more let's bring in DW
correspondent banditry Gert she is
standing by right on the french-german
border between the french town of a full
bar and to the German city
saarbrücken and bount you are on the
German side now those new checks they've
just taken effect is traffic still
rolling well you have to wait at least
30 minutes until you can enter from
France to Germany you have to get to
this checkpoint which you can see behind
me
the police is stopping every car now
checking if there are Germans in the car
or other nationals
Germans can go on on the right lane they
can enter Germany of course others have
to go to another Check Point close to me
here where 20 police men are asking
people what are you doing in Germany
what's the purpose of your visit and
only if you're a commuter if you have
your work place in Germany then you're
allowed to enter or others will have to
turn around and go back to France
and also trucks can enter deliveries of
goods is is not hampered by this effort
today so the border is not completely
closed but it's it's difficult to get
into Germany right now now of course
we're used very much to open borders by
now
how well-prepared are police doing those
checks well police is present here since
midnight already as I said there are 20
people here on the ground of course it's
difficult to mend this post it's not
only this one there are many checks
checkpoints along the French German
border and police officer told me it's
very difficult to get all the personnel
in place and they don't know how long
they have to undertake this effort for
days weeks or even months nobody knows
so far and there are no facilities
because this is a makeshift border
crossing this Autobahn has no border
crossing installed because the the
border was open for 25 years it's all
about curbing the spread of the
coronavirus what safety measures are
taken in place well the police is
working without any protective gear only
if there's a suspicious case if they see
somebody sneezing coughing in their cars
then they would protect themselves they
just keep a kind of distance they don't
touch people but the police tell me this
is what all German citizens should do
and there is no need to have a mask and
the fear that they might contract
coronavirus you on the border is not
very
hi among the police personnel all right
band Regas they're reporting from the
French German border for us thank you so
much so that's the situation on the
French a German border right now for
more on the political situation here in
Germany let's bring in our chief
political editor
Mishler Kirchner michaela the response
to this outbreak is snowballing here in
Germany we've seen certain increases in
restrictions in the capital Berlin is
the rest of Germany following suit with
closures of bars schools other
institutions and so forth well I
wouldn't say that brother really is at
the forefront of these closures we are
expecting today to hear from Bavaria the
state that directly borders Austria
where people are told to stay indoors
already and that a state of emergency
might be declared there this against the
backdrop that communal elections only
took place on Sunday so we are seeing
very regional reactions tough reactions
as well and we are yet to see a full
nationwide lockdown which also would be
more in the sense of advice giving from
Berlin because after all this is a
federal state but we have seen very
tough action as we heard from Bantry
Gert already taken on the border to
France where people are being told by
the interior ministry that declared
these border checks only on Sunday
evening that they should carry documents
that prove that they are indeed
traveling back and forth from their job
or else that's the big question mark
will learn that of the coming hours
whether people actually might be turned
away and simply because they can't prove
that they are on a necessary trip now
you know we hear that the German army is
also being drafted in to provide some
kind of support what exactly is their
role yes they will provide logistical
support also and the German army has
several hospitals so hospital staff from
the German army might help out in other
Hospital
also beds that would usually be reserved
more for the national forces would be
available for the public more so than
already in the past so what we're seeing
here is different agencies acting
together all right Michelle hakuna there
thank you so much chief her political
editor of course thank you and now two
other coronavirus hotspots around Europe
like Spain France and Italy which are
among the worst affected by the outbreak
Spain has followed Italy by imposing a
lockdown banning a 47 million citizens
from leaving their homes after the
government declared a 2-week state of
emergency in Paris dozens of people
gathered outdoors on Sunday despite the
French government closing all
non-essential businesses and urging
citizens to limit interaction meanwhile
Italy remains on the frontline of the
virus in Europe on Sunday 368 new
coronavirus related deaths were reported
there the worst single day toll for any
country since the crisis began and our
correspondent Seema Gupta is standing by
for us in Rome Seema Italian authorities
have registered 20,000 violations
against the lockdown in recent days our
people they are not taking the
restriction seriously well Monica I
think it's a question of also not
understanding how they can and cannot
apply those restrictions to be fair it's
20,000 violations in the space of about
four days and that is of a country of 60
million people that are currently in
lockdown to give you an idea of the kind
of confusion we're hearing the
statements such as this gentleman that
we have in sound therefore C Ghazi I'd
rather be punished than have my dog
urinate in my apartment of the woman
well such a gentleman for instance
doesn't understand that yes you can
bring your dog out of the apartment you
can bring it for what try to contain the
amount of time that you go out and avoid
other people that's what the officials
are saying essentially one can move out
they have a valid reason for work for
health emergency offers essential
activity such as walking one's dog
getting the groceries going to the
pharmacy or even going to pick up the
paper because the newsstand is
considered essential information because
the public needs to have access to
information to understand what's going
on what's going on in particular in the
north of the country the concern is that
they have to try to limit the spread of
the virus in that part of the country
but also the rest of the country and
hospitals while the situation is dire up
north down south they're also preparing
for eventual more infections well what
you're talking about a very dire
situation we're seeing a high rate of
deaths in Italy especially compared to
the situation in South Korea for example
how do you explain that well first off
as the Prime Minister mentioned when
this lockdown was put in place for the
entire country the impact of the
lockdown is only going to be felt in a
couple of weeks and we're still within
that frame the infections that one is
seeing now these high numbers which are
immense are unfortunately a result of
infections that took place before the
lockdown and on top of that if one looks
at the first original towns those 11
towns that were originally put under
quarantine they've actually seen a
slowdown in infection there but
unfortunately the infections that we're
seeing now is a result of before the
lockdown on top of that the number of
deaths one has to remember that a
quarter of the Italian population is
over the age of 65 so it's one of the
oldest populations in the world as a
result of this unfortunately the virus
does tend to impact the more vulnerable
of society so those who are elderly or
those that have underlying health
conditions so unfortunately because of
that we're seeing these high numbers
yeah I mean let's talk a bit about the
psychological the emotional stress of
this situation because we're hearing
reports about people dying not being
able to say goodbye to their their
children their loved ones because of the
contact ban what's that do to the
Italian society
well Italians as we know are tactile
people there are people
who are used to contact that they have a
sense a strong sense of family as well
in contact with one's family so yes
you're right this is going to have a
potentially negative impact in terms of
the psychological damage not just to the
fact that children aren't able to meet
their school friends or go to school and
have a normal social life in that
respect but people understand that this
is necessary in order to live at the
spread that's why the use of technology
has become so important video calls with
friends with family even with a
psychologist online that are available
or taking to doing sport indoors and
following the yoga lessons online these
are some of the examples that people
have disappeared to and proving how
technology is so important on top of
that we've seen these flash mobs where
people have come up onto their balconies
onto their outside of their windows in
order to have a sense of solidarity as
they deal with this epidemic very very
important some morale boost their
correspondent Seema Gupta in Rome thank
you so much 47 million Spaniards are now
banned from leaving their homes for the
next two weeks after the Prime Minister
declared a state of emergency more than
280 people have died in Spain making it
the second worst affected country in
Europe now let's go to Madrid where
correspondent Marcos burnish is a
standing by for us Marcos it seems like
they're taking this lockdown very
seriously tell me about the timing why
did he had to impose these restrictions
now maybe they were already too late
because we have an exponential
development with the figures in Spain
and therefore they had to act because we
have 2,000 more infections from one day
to the other and on Saturday the Prime
Minister already announced that he was
expecting
if infections by 10 thousands during
this week and it could be that we it
will come
to this figure already today we will
have the latest figures by noon and that
we will see how this exponential
development is continuing it is sure
that they had to do something and of
experts say that it will last at least
two weeks to see if these measures will
be effective and all these drastic
measures and this crisis of course comes
where Spain just about emerged from a
very severe economic crisis and more
than half of all jobs in Spain are with
small and medium sized companies now
very much affected how worried are
spaniards about the economic impact of
those measures it is a catastrophe
without any doubt because tourism the
most relevant services a sector is is
destroyed right now it is on hold I try
to film last night in hotels I had an
appointment there and the hotel was
already closed so hotels one after the
other
are closing down flights are cancelled
and even the internal traffic in Spain
stopped
so almost stopped so we have companies
bigger companies like Volkswagen who
decided to close their production plant
here in Spain and others will follow so
tomorrow is the crucial day where the
government will decide how to react on
this situation how to well rescue the
economy all right Marcus furnish their
report
from Madrid thank you so much so
Europeans governments try to stop the
spread of coronaviruses much as they can
I'm joined by our science correspondent
Derek Williams who is currently in
self-isolation good to see you Derek
from a scientific point of view chicks
at the borders partial closures of
borders do these measures help curb the
spread of coronavirus well to be
perfectly honest we don't really know
this is all unprecedented you know
science is all about is about working on
precedents and we have absolutely no
experience with this kind of a situation
so it's all uncharted territory that
said it seems that a lot of
epidemiologists in the run-up to the -
tube this morning we're saying closing
borders will help slow the spread of the
virus but not probably dramatically once
it's endemic within a population then
the only thing that seems to work in
terms of containment is going into
lockdown as we saw in China China didn't
shut its borders it went into lockdown
within the country itself and that that
helped to limit the spread of the virus
within the population lockdowns like
we're seeing similar lockdowns in Spain
and Italy now that said as well it's
gonna take a couple of weeks before you
see any kind of impact because this
virus has an incubation period and so
people were spreading it up until the
moment of lockdown within Italy and it
will take at least two weeks to see any
kind of impact and the numbers hopefully
at that point after two weeks they'll
start to go down but it gets worse
before it gets better
okay is this all very unnerving also
especially because online were bombarded
with information about what to do in the
current crisis and the latest news that
caused a stir was about the effects that
taking ibuprofen might have on those
third half of the virus what was all
that about well I I got there was a it
was interesting in German there was a
whatsapp a message that was sent out
yesterday that made big waves I got it
myself from it from a science journalist
colleague of mine
a woman saying that at the university
clinic and Vienna they had discovered
that taking ibuprofen worsens the course
of the disease the university clinic
immediately came out and said no that's
fake news there we didn't conduct any
studies in that direction that's not
true but things were complicated by the
fact that then the French Health
Minister came out and said actually that
there was a connection with ibuprofen he
himself is a doctor now biologists have
now gone on record saying there is no
scientific proof that ibuprofen which
also interacts with some of the
receptors that involve there are active
with the coronavirus apparently there is
however no scientific proof that there
is a connection between those two things
it's just a hypothesis okay more
confusion there probably Derrick
Williams in self-isolation thank you so
much and here's a look now at more of
the latest coronavirus developments
China has started putting all
international arrivals to the country's
capital Beijing and quarantine it
reported a total of 16 new cases on
Monday 12 of those who were people
arriving from abroad Iran has reported
130 new deaths from coronavirus that
takes the death toll there - more than
720 in Azula has ordered residents to
stay at home under quarantine in seven
of its states including the capital
Caracas Peru has declared a state of
emergency and ordered security forces to
help impose self quarantine of the
population it has also closed its
borders and the death toll from the
corona virus in the United States has
risen to over 60 with 3,000 confirmed
cases of the illness the federal reserve
has again dropped interest rates in a
bid to boost the coronavirus hit economy
and more and more states are ordering
the closure of bars and movie theaters
go home shout these New Yorkers to
passersby
others using their balconies to preach
to people to stay indoors even retail
stores like Apple turning people away a
sign of just how seriously corporate
America is taking the coronavirus the
economic costs of this pandemic though
are hurting especially after last week's
financial meltdown in a surprise move
the US Federal Reserve has slashed
interest rates to almost zero and
pledged hundreds of billions of dollars
to help shore up the US economy a
decision welcomed by a president
desperate for better headlines it's
really good news it's really great for
our country it's something that we're
very happy I have to say this I'm very
happy Trump also found himself pleading
to Americans to stop hoarding you don't
have to buy so much take it easy just
relax people are going in and they're
buying more they I remember I guess
during the conversation Doug of Walmart
said that they're buying more than they
buy a Christmas relax we're doing great
it all will pass but for citizens like
Carol Schrader it doesn't feel that way
she's one of thousands who's been caught
up in the chaos of trying to get back to
the States ahead of trumps travel ban no
consistency in questioning no
temperature check no swabs not
we were given a five page document on
forever letters while many Americans are
now living in lockdown others are trying
to carry on as if nothing has changed
but with a state of emergency declared
across the country no one will be able
to ignore the coronavirus for long Obama
let's go to our correspondent Oliver
Sally in Washington Oliver Trump is
urging the public to relax but the top
US health official has told Americans to
prepare to hunker down is there mixed
messaging here yeah what was really
astonishing here is that turnaround that
we've seen here coming from the White
House you know President Trump has
really tried to downplay this crisis
here he's been talking about the corona
virus comparing it to a flu and in just
a very few days later he declared a
nationwide state of emergency and
Anthony Fauci
that you just quoted America's top
expert if you will and infectious
diseases he said that the worst is yet
to come so we do get these mixed
messages and we also see a president who
seems really little informed about the
details of the corona virus and the
impact it has and he has also been lying
to the public about the number of tests
that were done in the United States and
he's also been trying to distract from
this crisis you know by comparing and
especially blaming is a predecessor
Barrack Obama about how his
administration dealt with the swine flu
so a lot of this we've we've experienced
here is the usual Donald Trump if you
will but what's crucial right now is
that he's not able to calm the American
public down and and really stirring up
even more confusion here among the
public
so for Trump this is a very damaging
scenario and a very damaging reality
that he finds himself in with this
global pandemic happening that is also
affecting the United States of course
every day more so and that all of that
and the economic fallout stemming from
this is putting a considerable strain on
his reelection campaign yeah this is why
probably he was very pleased
about the US Federal Reserve taking
drastic action action that we haven't
seen since the height of the financial
crisis in 2008 what's the aim there yeah
and that's just like you say that's also
why it's such a dramatic step because
the last time that happened was right
after the Lehman crash of 2008 that led
to the worldwide financial crisis and
it's a very significant step also
because this is considered when a when a
when a central bank cuts their interest
rates to zero as a last resort to boost
the economy and you mentioned that Trump
has been calling for this step for a
long time because obviously a booming
economy would help him to get reelected
the Fed has always rejected that but now
they also believe it's necessary it's
sort of like admitting that the u.s. is
getting close to a recession and that
this really needs to happen right now to
help the economy but we're not talking
about a booming economy anymore this is
rather about avoiding the worst looming
bankruptcies and mass unemployment
now the coronavirus also played a key
role in the latest democratic debate
tell us a little bit more about that
yeah well first of all there was no
audience because of the coronavirus so
the debate was supposed to be held in
Phoenix Arizona where they're going to
be primary elections next week and it
was then moved to Washington DC held
without any audience at all but of
course the coronavirus was also a very
important aspect of the debate and both
had some unity here by arguing that
President Trump does not have the
situation under control
alright Olivas Ali there reporting from
Washington thank you so much and let's
get you up to speed now on some other
stories making headlines around the
world Spain's King Philippe er has
stripped his father former monarch Juan
Carlos of his annual allowances from the
royal household the move follows alleged
financial irregularities involving the
former King the current monarch has also
renounced any personal inheritance he
could receive from his
German tourism giant tui has announced
it was suspending the bulk of its
operations due to the corona virus
outbreak the company employs 70,000
worldwide - he confirmed the measures
would affect its package travel crews
and hotel businesses did u.s. president
donít Trump tried to buy up a German
company leading the race for a corona
virus vaccine Berlin has reacted angrily
to reports that Trump offered by a
pharma company cure vac 1 billion
dollars to develop a vaccine exclusively
for the United States foreign minister
hai Kumar said that Berlin could not
allow others exclusive rights to German
research economy minister peter altmire
was blunter germany he said is not for
sale
searching for a breakthrough this queue
of a collab in southwest germany hopes
to be the first in the race to develop a
vaccine against the corona virus and is
being noticed with reports surfacing
Donald Trump is trying to lure the
company to the u.s. Berlin is
encouraging the biopharmaceutical firm
to stay ok we are seeing a lot of
political support and the issue is taken
very seriously from various sites
specifically we have received support
from an international vaccine initiative
so that these clinical trials can also
quickly begin here clinician felucca
beginnings occur the company says
research into several possible vaccines
has begun with the two most promising to
be chosen for clinical tests it expects
to have an experimental vaccine
developed by June or July and will then
seek approval for testing on humans
Kovacs specializes in a method called
RNA which makes human cells produce
proteins that trigger immune responses
against infections or cancers these are
currently and on this basis we are now
building that new vaccine we now have a
platform process where we can quickly
respond to new threats so we believe
that this RNA technology is a very good
way to quickly provide
Lucian's and their Buddhist middle-aged
nailers on answer beaten if the vaccine
is successful in human trials Kovacs
says up to ten million doses could be
produced in several weeks experts
originally thought a vaccine would be 18
months away meaning a successful human
trial as early as July would be welcomed
by the global community the Bank of
Japan has unveiled a series of emergency
monetary policy measures to shore up the
world's third-largest economy amid the
corona virus pandemic the news however
doesn't seem to be calming investors
tokyo's Nikkei fell after early gains
and Australia's index tumbled nearly 10
percent its biggest loss ever markets in
Hongkong and Shanghai were also trading
lower that after Chinese authorities
released data showing just how much
damage the corona virus has done to the
world's second-largest economy
retail sales have dropped 20 point five
percent and industrial output fell by
13.5 percent for more I'm joined by Mira
some on the investment director at
fidelity investment joining me in Hong
Kong go to be with us Maeda the latest
numbers from China didn't really come in
as a surprise yet markets drop how low
can this go well if you look at what's
happening with the markets really it's
really sentiment that's having an impact
and this sentiment impact is because of
two sort of Black Swan events because of
say the corona virus as well as the fall
in the oil price oil and and and that's
exactly what's having on investor minds
right so what we really need to see is
that when where is this medical issue
going to go it's yes central banks are
providing some kind of bomb or cure to
the market but it's not really a cure
it's a bomb right right but but I mean
central banks and investors where we
don't know just let me ask you I mean
investors they look for some sense of
security and central banks have stepped
in why isn't it enough investors to
somehow help stabilize the market well
at the end of the day when you look at
what's happening with respect to
economic data what we are seeing is a
contraction in demand as well as
activity and until we see that people
are comfortable enough to step out of
their houses and then come in and fill
this demand demand we don't think we are
likely to see markets recover from a
sentiment perspective okay so we need a
sense again
need a sense of normality I get from you
meter some amount of fidelity investment
in Hong Kong fingers fish meanwhile
European markets also started trading
and my colleague Chelsea Delaney keeps
an eye on the trading floor in Frankfurt
Chelsea how our investors they're
holding up well it has been a harrowing
past week for investors and it's not
looking any better here at the start of
shrinking trading and here in Frankfurt
the docks just open and it's down
already about 7% just really a dramatic
fall and we've seen a lot of a lot of
news over the weekend of increasing
restrictions on businesses on trade on
travel that's all going to have a
significant impact but the measures that
central banks and governments are
putting in place to really help prop up
the economy just aren't convincing
investors the Fed the Bank of Japan all
are coming out with a lot of a lot of
easing measures cuts to interest rates
and governments also here in Germany for
example they've unveiled unlimited
credit for businesses but investors
aren't sure if that's going to be enough
to offset the economic impact I chose to
delay in Frankfurt thank you so much now
South Korea has been among the country's
worst affected by the new coronavirus
spot South Korean businesses are working
together to share the economic burden
from kovat 19
south korean landlords and tenants are
sharing the burden of weathering the
decline in business caused by the corona
virus outbreak with reductions in rents
large traditional markets especially
needed the help we used to get an
average 300,000 visitors a day but since
the corona virus outbreak began we've
been seeing less than 1/10 of our usual
number of customers business owners here
have been suffering immensely not only
domestic sales are affected as
international trade has also din deled
especially for small exporters as shown
among Korea has a competitive global
edge in the fashion industry and its
products are high in demand overseas but
now that foreign buyers can't even enter
Korea coupled with slowing fabric
shipments and fewer visitors to the
market overall it's having quite a large
ripple effect in addition to the rent
reductions market managers have also
coordinated strict Public Health
responses some landlords have provided
up to 50% off in rent although smaller
reductions are more common but even
those providing the discounts argue for
more state-led measures met Judy
complementing revenues of the merchants
biggest concern so tax remedies are
needed although the government has
announced new tax breaks a lower income
tax means little if merchants aren't
making much to begin with so many want
to see a decrease in value-added taxes
the large traditional markets rely on
both tourism and elder shoppers both of
which have dried up although more
assistance may be coming merchants here
in seoul's Namdaemun market and around
south korea are soon likely to get some
more help from the federal government
the National Assembly is set to pass a
multi-billion dollar supplementary
budget to
poor at small businesses and to help
contain and mitigate the kovat 19
outbreak the so-called nice landlord
trend has also brought banks into the
movement with low interest loans as
South Korea copes with a deepening covet
19 crisis at our people coping with the
prospect of having to spend time in
isolation well people in Italy they've
been trying to keep up morale by singing
with their neighbours from the safety of
their balconies one tenant Florence has
been serenading his street for the last
few days who leave you now with some of
his music as always thanks for joining
us
[Music]